- [Narrator] TikTok is at a crossroads.
Concerns about its Chinese ownership
have been building since 2020.
- TikTok's been in this
limbo for two years,
and who knows how many more months
or years it could stay in this limbo.
- [Narrator] And a panel of US officials
is torn on how to address them.
If they can't come to an agreement,
there's another possible solution,
forcing TikTok to become a US company.
Here's what it would
take to make that happen,
and why that move poses
some big challenges.
First, a brief review of how
TikTok's data is managed,
which is the main focus for US officials.
- TikTok's this huge
company, but it's owned
by a Chinese parent
company called ByteDance.
They run several apps,
but TikTok is probably their
best known one in the world.
- [Narrator] ByteDance itself
is headquartered in Beijing,
and is owned by investors
from around the globe.
A Chinese state controlled entity
owns 1% of a Beijing based
subsidiary of ByteDance.
Those connections are what
some are worried about,
and for a couple of reasons.
- The first concern is that
the Chinese government could order TikTok
to hand over data about
individual American users.
So what kind of videos they watch,
and maybe even their IP addresses,
which could identify their location.
The second big thing
is the video recommendation algorithm,
and the idea is that
the Chinese government
could order TikTok to control
what videos Americans could watch.
- [Narrator] TikTok says
it has already started
to address some of those concerns.
The company recently said that
all US user traffic is now being routed
through cloud servers operated
by the US based company Oracle.
And TikTok says that only members
of its US data security team
have access to that data.
But backups are still being saved
to other non-Oracle servers in the US
and Singapore, the company says,
but it's phasing those out.
As for TikTok's recommendation algorithm,
that was created by its Chinese
parent company ByteDance.
TikTok says changes to the
algorithm are monitored
by Oracle before they're
implemented in the US app.
- So anytime there's a change
to the algorithm that influences
what kind of videos Americans see,
they see that Oracle will
have full access to see,
you know, what the algorithm does.
- [Narrator] A spokesperson
for the Chinese Foreign Ministry
said in a press conference in November
in regards to TikTok that
"Spreading disinformation
and then using it to
hobble Chinese companies
has become a go-to tool
for the US government."
But some US lawmakers still want TikTok
to have more separation from China.
One option is a divestiture
order or a forced sale,
which could cut ties to Chinese ownership.
- The Chinese government would
theoretically have less power over TikTok,
to force TikTok to do something like spy
or control what videos Americans watch.
- [Narrator] A divestiture
order is what happened
to the dating app Grindr in 2019,
after US officials determined
that the app's personal data
could potentially be
exploited for blackmail,
since the majority stakeholder
was a Chinese company.
Here's how the process
has worked in past cases.
First, an executive body branch called
the Committee on Foreign
Investment in the United States,
or CFIUS, opens a case with
the involved companies.
This is the panel that's
been talking to TikTok.
It's made up of representatives
of nine US departments and agencies,
led by the Treasury,
and reviews foreign transactions to see
if they might be a national security risk.
After CFIUS reviews a company or merger,
it can make recommendations
to mitigate those risks,
which can include asking foreign investors
or owners to sell their
stake in the company.
In extreme cases, it can
also escalate the case
to the president, who
can order a forced sale.
That owner then has to
find a suitable buyer,
usually one within the US.
Then the buyer and seller
might have to go back
to CFIUS in order to
get the sale approved.
Grindr took just over a year
after the order was made
to find a buyer and get approval.
The president never issued an order.
But TikTok is a much bigger name
and forcing a sale could
be more complicated.
- There's been nothing of
this scale, this popularity.
Usually, you know, CFIUS deals
with a lot smaller cases here.
So this is like the case
of the century for CFIUS
lawyers in Washington in DC.
- [Narrator] A treasury official
said that CFIUS does not publicly comment
on transactions that it may
or may not be reviewing.
Officials are worried about
a number of challenges
facing a forced sale.
One is that the Trump
administration already tried it.
- They have till September
15th to make a deal.
After that, we closed
it up in this country.
- [Narrator] In 2020, that administration
issued an order that would've
effectively banned TikTok,
unless it sold itself to a US buyer.
But TikTok pushed back and took the order
to a federal appeals court,
arguing that the deal denied
the company due process.
It was still tied up in legal issues
by the time Joe Biden got into office,
and the order was shelved
as his administration conducted
its own security review.
But his administration
could face similar pushback
from TikTok if it tries to force a sale,
and doing so could risk
diluting CFIUS' authority.
- Their power is based on having
these vague broad powers,
and if they go to court,
even if they win in court,
a court might put parameters
on that power, might define that power,
'cause the more vague your power is,
the more powerful it is.
- [Narrator] Even without legal hurdles,
a sale would also need cooperation
from the Chinese government,
which has the power to restrict
the exports of technology,
such as TikTok's video
recommendation algorithm.
- If China does not allow
the algorithm to be sold,
then can TikTok continue
operating in the US?
We don't know.
We're in totally uncharted
waters right now.
- [Narrator] While CFIUS
decides what to do,
some lawmakers have taken
concerns into their own hands.
TikTok has been banned
on government devices
in a majority of states.
And in December,
the federal government
implemented a similar ban.
- The only sensible next step
is for this congress
to act to make that ban
across the board for all federal devices.
- [Narrator] At least one bill
has been introduced to ban TikTok
entirely in the United States.
- That has legal problems too.
That could potentially face
a First Amendment problem.
Can you actually stop,
can you actually ban TikTok
from operating in the US?
Especially when it has more
than 100 million American users.
- [Narrator] While TikTok
has made concessions,
including how its data is managed,
to get to an agreement with CFIUS,
talks are ongoing
without a clear deadline.
(upbeat music)